لكن يعني
عندما عندما يسقط المبنى بهذا الشكل الذي
نراه خلفك هل يمكن
تحديد الاتجاهات لهذا المبنى بحيث يعرف
مثلا اتجاهات الشقق او المنازل التي كان
موجوده التي كانت موجوده في هذا المبنى
للذهاب مباشره نحو الاماكن التي يتوقع ان
يكون فيها
اناس اكانوا احياء ام جثث يعني هل يمكن
هذا الامر ان يحصل خصوصا وان الزلزال قد
حصل في في ساعات الفجر
وعمليا معظم الناس ستكون في غرف النوم
بطبيعه الحال
بل هو سؤال يمكن ان يشير الى نقطه مهمه هي
كيف يتصرف الانسان في حال حدود زلزال
طبيعيا بلا شعور
غالبا ما يتجه الانسان نحو المخرج عندما
سالت بعض
فرق الانقاذ التي كانت تعمل امس سالتهم
لماذا يتم العمل في من الاعلى الى الاسفل
فقالوا انه غالبا ما يتجه الناس نحو
السلالم نحو الادراج وذلك اما للهرب او
الاحتماء بها كونها قد تكون هي الاسلم في
حاله الانهيارات وبالتالي يتم البحث في
تلك النقاط هذا ما سمعته ولكن علميا قد
يكون له تفسير اخر ولكن السؤال الذي طرحته
سببه ان الاشخاص الذين يحاولون الهرب هم
دائما يحاولون الذهاب نحو المخرج وهذا هو
سبب ربما التركيز تركيز البحث في هذه
النقاط الفريق الذي جاء اليوم هو استمع
الى عده نقاط في محيط محيط هذا الركام لم
يكتفي بالاستماع من اعلى هو استعمى من
الجوانب كلها قاموا بمد
عنا نقول اسلاك طويله الى داخل رفقه اضاءه
واجهزه صوت واستمعوا ومن بعدها طلب
المسؤول الذي كان يرافق هؤلاء هذا الفريق
المكون من ست او سبع اشخاص طالب
بالصمت التام حتى انه طلب من الناس الناس
الا تكون واقفه طلب منها ان تجثوا حتى
تهدا الحركه تماما ومن ثم طلب المتطوعين
ابن المتطوعين من اداره الطوارئ والكوارث
الدوليه
سمح لهم بالصعود لمساعده الفريق الاساسي
وبالتالي عمليه الانقاذ انتقلت الى مرحله
جديده نحن الان نرى ان الالات التي كانت
تحفر التراب هي المتوقفه حاليا لكن الاله
في الاعلى هي تحاول ان تساعد بازاله
الاحجار الكبيره من هذا المكان
علهم يفتحون ممرا او يفتحون ثغره يستطيعون
من خلالها التاكد فيما اذا كان هناك
ناجونه في المكان ام لا حسن
شكرا لك